est-ce que vous avez la rage de vivre
non et pourquoi non pourquoi parce que
j'ai la rage de survivre mais pas la
rage de vivre est-ce que vous avez la
rage ne pas réussir à vous pas fait
correctement
bon ben ça s'est passé il ya plus de
rage je n'y arrive pas je n'y arrive pas
depuis 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans tant pis
comment ouais non c'est bien pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez la rage de voir
chirac président au début pas du tout
ouais vous début pas du tout il a fait
un très beau discours au sujet de la
france la français de vichy il a
installé des canons dessus de sarajevo
pour arrêter les massacres
bon je te plutôt pour aujourd'hui je
trouve très très très usés et puis pas
mal
usant est-ce que vous avez la rage de ne
pas avoir changé le monde je l'échangé
voilà excusez moi mais parmi tous les
révolutionnaires petit peuple absolument
toute la france bat depuis 50 ans j'ai
soutenu des révolutions qui ont réussi
est-ce que vous avez la rage quand
bernard lévy vend plus de livres que
vous m'a écouté au début c'était pas le
cas ensuite ça l'a été
maintenant je m'en fous lui je le
suppose il s'en fout aussi et on est à
ses copains est-ce que vous avez la rage
en ayant les filles de 20 ans avec leurs
petits seins de bakélite de bakélite
gainsbourg à elle peut pas tous les ans
nous flânons enfin des petits singes
adore et des gros seins
et si j'ai la rage
oui oui oui et non ça mais extrêmement
mal à l'aise
ça dure depuis très longtemps et je
trouve que les français sont aussi mal à
l'aise mais avec mauvaise conscience
c'est à dire qu'il ne donne pas une
pièce de monnaie
moi j'ai vécu dans un village en 80 le
tout le village voter à gauche
et puis il ya un gars qui est mort dans
une grange avec mort de froid et tout le
village s'est retournée en dix ans mais
c'est la faute au gouvernement alors que
n'importe qui aurait pu les berges et
donc ouvrir ça me donne ça me donne
froid dans le dos est-ce que vous avez
la rage en voyant la place de la france
dans le monde
oui oui oui je trouve que c'est
lamentable
la france aujourd'hui elle se bat sur
quoi elle se bat sur la pac et sur les
5,5 pour cent pour la restauration
ouais bon écoutez excusez moi mais dans
le monde tel qu'il est il ya des ya des
causes plus grande et la france
normalement il aurait dû se féliciter ne
serait-ce que se féliciter de la
libération de l'ukraine de la géorgie
elle devrait s'inquiéter des guerres
absolument affreuse pas seulement en
tchétchénie mais aussi au darfour est là
elle est la grande absente
est-ce que vous avez la rage de voir que
milo selick ne sera pas jugée non paix à
son âme
je pense simplement que c'est une
critique affaire au tribunal c'est la
dure est ton nom tu es ce que vous avez
la rage de voir mourir un jour
ah non pas du tout ça me rassure plutôt
ouais bah oui ça me rassure sur mon état
de
décrépitude ça s'arrêtera est-ce que
vous avez la rage quand vous prenez un
râteau et qu'une femme on veut sinon ça
me paraît à peu près normale
enfin je suis plutôt étonnés de l'
inverse est-ce que vous avez la rage
quand on vous prend pour un vieux fou
toujours en colère non mais ça m'embête
way